mais malgré sept décès l'annoncé lundi à
nantes lors du comité interministériel
les habitants du littoral atlantique
sont toujours en colère à saint nazaire
collectif anti marée noire vient de
lancer une pétition pour abroger un
protocole de 92 qui modifiait la loi
internationale en matière
d'indemnisation des pollutions maritimes
un texte qui vous allez le comprendre
des douanes les pétroliers pollueurs les
explications de christine le héros
depuis le naufrage de l'erika d'une
seule voix les militantes imari noir
vise total fina pour eux le pollueur et
le payeur or total fina ne peut pas être
poursuivi c'est la loi internationale
qui le dit pourquoi pascal braud a
trouvé la réponse dans ce texte de 92
signé notamment par la france il modifie
la précédente convention de 69 tout
affréteurs d'un navire est exonéré de
poursuites en cas de marée noire c'est à
dire que concrètement la société total
est exonéré de toutes poursuites civiles
sur le plan de la marée noire donc on
peut toujours taper sur total c'est
l'état qui va payer plein pot la facture
en 92 le nouveau texte signé notamment
par le gouvernement français augmente
sensiblement le fonds d'indemnisation
mais dans le même temps effectivement
les pétroliers eux se mettent à l'abri
c'est insidieux a été constituée en 92
sous la pression très forte des
compagnies pétrolières une un mur
juridique faisant qu'elle était à moins
que ce soit pour leurs propres flottes
qu'elle était en dehors de la
responsabilité et des propriétaires de
navires et du fipol ce fonds
international d'indemnisation
seule une faute grave pourrait entraîner
des poursuites judiciaires et
financières contre total fina une faute
grave comme par exemple avoir transporté
une matière illégal ce que démontrent
les premières analyses de ce laboratoire
indépendant par contre il est prouvé
qu'il s'agit pas d'un produits
valorisables mais bien pêcher de
raffineries
ce moment là le principe de libre
circulation ne s'applique plus c'est pas
une mars on dévalorise âge il aurait
fallu appliquer le principe de proximité
qui exclut toute exportation et qui
impose même la destruction dans les
règles dans l'installation de
destruction la plus proche du lieu de
production et pour en avoir le coeur net
ce laboratoire critiqué pour ses
analyses demande une contre expertise
pour prouver si oui ou non total fina
peut être finalement poursuivi